[Music]
what are your thoughts on ideas and
strategies to get the mainstream
celebrity pop-culture influencer into
ecology league to grow the awareness of
it zero it's already happening if
Charlie from tick-tock who's gone from
zero to 7.5 million followers in
tick-tock in a month you know boyfriend
next year is a Call of Duty player
that's way better than paying LeBron a
million to say he's watching the match
this has been written written you got
your YouTube what's up so so grateful
that you clicked and you're about to
watch a new youtube video but before you
do - 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 that is my
texting community platform doing a lot
of one-on-one engagement in there and
also access opportunity first looks in
that environment
- 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 join it now and now
to the video you've been wanting to
watch and I'd love to open it up to very
like listen we're here so very specific
whether it's 101 questions or very
specific or selfish to your business I'd
love to answer anything I can help you
with hey Gary Josh BT Josh I got a fun
one for you please all I've really come
away from right now is I feel like a bad
father because I've been kicking my son
off of his video game system
yes for years yeah I may have destroyed
his future by great um likely and I'm
terrified about the people sitting
behind me that are probably about to
throw things that maybe yes they now
know that about yes
help me I'm a business owner right I
want to make sure I make smart decisions
in my business life let's consider this
his business life what games should I be
pushing him to play right now so that in
five years he's a billionaire I how old
is he he's 11 okay so 16 year old
billionaire we can make this happen
together let me say this let me say this
the answer is I don't know I'm sure
there's a lot of people here who are
deep enough in all of gaming and and
casual gaming I think all of us can
agree if you think of Minecraft from an
engineering standpoint or other things
if you're really objective there are
incredible amounts of game that's out
there that speak to honing your math
skills your engineering skills your
intuitive skill there's so much value
from it
I would tell every I would level this
conversation up there's a lot of parents
in here grandparents aunts uncles
sisters brothers we demonize technology
in a world where our children will only
live in a more technology centric world
the thought that you put writing a
letter on a pedestal today but but being
on your iPad for an extra half an hour
as a negative parents and humans are
inherently
in the business of no yesterday beer
I've two children ten and seven
I am uncomfortably comfortable with them
being in a non technology every second
of their life now they won't because
that's not how the world works today but
it has been fascinating for me to watch
the current state of parenting a
demonize technology but then use it to
shut their kids up when they are
drinking wine or hanging out with their
friends I hate I mean I've literally
this is actually happened in my life
because of who I am and you go with the
parents from the school they were like
yell at me about social media or
technology but then we're like hitting
it off because it's like the second time
the group is getting together and their
kid comes and they throw the iPad at
them like it's a like it's a ninja star
and like and say go over there like it's
the the parenting hypocrisy in 2020 is
laughable at best and more importantly
much like the parents that did actually
ruin so many kids over the last 20 years
chance to make 10 million a year being a
gamer who are now $137,000 year lawyers
and unhappy or even or even not a
hundred thirty-seven there's there's
some person right now who was supposed
to be Tony Hawk who was supposed to be
Kelly Slater aka
ninja before ninja the great pioneer of
eSports she or he is probably 38 to 45
because that would have been a time but
she was told she has to go to college he
has to like it happens every day and I
couldn't be more counter to the current
political correctness of parenting with
technology I beg for you to debate the
world you think your children will be
living in 25 years I remind you that
over the last every day that humans have
been alive we have underestimated humans
ability and the brain's ability to
adjust to the reality of the world
please go read the articles written
newspapers about the Kaleidoscope I'm
being serious and how the Kaleidoscope
was gonna ruin the human race because
children were running around Europe
putting their eye in a kaleidoscope and
weren't paying attention to the real
world we demonize Instagram feeds
parents who laid in bed as teenagers and
went through Vogue and Seventeen
magazine and we're on 3-way chat with
their girlfriends for seven hours a day
demonize children going through
Instagram laying up it's fascinating and
it's what has led to a lot of
unhappiness in our society and and I
hope that me conversating about it you
know one of the great things of amassing
awareness is it allows you to talk about
things that you truly believe in that
may spark conversation we are such lazy
parents today technology bad how about
let's actually build self-esteem in our
kids which then will allow them to deal
with everything how about that
conversation oh but no it's not fun to
be accountable it's much more fun to
blame the Russians and Facebook that's
what I think we've got a question back
here in the back
hi Gary Mady here hey a quick question
what was a driving factor that had to
invent on that had you investing in call
of duty as opposed to maybe eSports that
are larger on the global scale like
League of Legends or dota 2 the
relationship with the Wilfs the
opportunity that was in front of me I
didn't I had opportunities with
overwatch I didn't want to go there my
own personal intuition of League of
Legends versus Call of Duty me being
comfortable with starting I back to my
miraculous capabilities of understanding
humans I'm at my prime with America I'm
getting really strong in Asia and the UK
and other places but I'm an 11 in
America I'm a 7.9 in other parts of the
world so that gave me triple confidence
the culture you know when I think when I
looked at who are the eighteen-year-old
basketball players
the seventeen-year-old rappers who are
the 13-year old tic-tock errs of today
that I believed subjectively on
intuition would be here in a decade and
what's their relationship with video
games Call of Duty is way up there so
that feels like cultural relevance for a
decade versus not that's the answer
you're welcome
I think what's fun about talks like this
is for a lot of you the way my content
is distributed is it's me cursing
heavily on LinkedIn or in a in a
30-second Instagram where I'm contextual
to that platform but I think you know at
least for me and I appreciate the tone
and tenor of this audience like I'm not
guessing out here there's a lot more
thinking going on here then I like to
play on the internet and I think for all
of you you know I'm starting to amass
enough wins on the board that me saying
that is not required anymore for more
people thoughtful people winning people
to be paying attention closer I'm
definitely not here for my health this
is not for kicks and giggles I believe
this is sports and music are the easiest
bets for the rest of your life and and
watching the evolution of both I would
be dispassionate if we were talking
about Latin trap if I was right now
talking about bad bunny and Becky G and
Nicky Jam I would be equally as fired up
because I believe they are grossly
underpriced and and Latin culture in the
u.s. specially within music is at scale
these people have people that just
rattled off have more followers than
your favorite artists you just don't
know it yet and that to me is the game
that will allow me to buy the Jets and
win a Super Bowl hi Gary Darren Glover
can you speak on the importance of like
the mainstream culture influencers it's
fascinating to hear all the analogies
that always pop up between where the
sports was and then how sports became
something crazy important but all these
relevant sports figures now that have
grown up with social media and have 2
million followers that play it's called
a duty or fortnight just as much as
maybe some of the pro eSports gamers I
now now have you know I
you mean the Juju's or like like other
sports stars playing these games
basically as you spoke about you I mean
you talk about all the time its
relevancy its its culture its life bunny
if that bunny plays plays fortnight that
how important is that to fortnight it
already happened exactly the
main event was ninja run Drake it
happened this is what I keep telling
everybody this has happened you might
not have decided to look at it you might
have not looked at it from the proper
lens but that's what mate for tonight
substantially grow I know that based on
your question and that's what's gonna
like I said I do not know the event that
will make the Call of Duty League go to
the next spear it will be something what
are your thoughts on ideas and
strategies to get the mainstream
celebrity pop culture influencer into
college beauty league to grow the
awareness of it zero it's already
happening we don't need to do it
they play it and love it it's happened
it's just just a moment away if Charlie
from tick-tock who's gone from zero to
7.5 million followers in tick-tock in a
month you know boyfriend next year is a
Call of Duty player that's way better
than paying LeBron a million to say he's
watching the match this has been written
written listen this is why people think
I predict things but I keep trying to
tell you I'm not I really appreciate it
but it's not deserved
um I'm regurgitating what's actually
happened I'm not [ __ ] Nostradamus
I'm regurgitating what's happened I just
happen to know where to look I might
just be willing to spend the 25 hours
you know took a month looking at the top
charts of the App Store to realize that
Yik yak was something six years ago but
that disappeared or that vine did this
where Socialcam did that where peach was
supposed to be this where Vero was
supposed to be that or musically did do
this and became tick-tock or path did
this I'm putting in the work
just like I'm watching youtube videos of
sophomores in high school right now to
figure out which college players are
gonna matter for Vayner sports it's just
work it's just work people don't take
work and put it into the right places
and they use media outlets to give them
headlines to form their opinions that's
the difference between what I do and
what most people do I'm actually in the
trenches being an anthropologist
strategist and actually doing the work
versus what most people do which is they
allow something in the middle to
consolidate the information for them and
allow them the bullet points in the
headlines and in that practitioner ship
is the Delta that has allowed me the
luxury and the honor of sitting up here
and being listened to the work so like
you were just talking about in terms of
doing the work yes I mean most people
don't do the work the right way within
the concept of like doing the work the
right way whether you're planning a
business or planning for your life how
do you view the distinction between like
execution and strategy like how much
should you be planning for your work
versus how much did you just be doing it
how do you he's a great question um for
me first of all the answer is
self-awareness it really is because for
you and I might be different but it's a
very important question right like
somebody once said something to me
Garret he said Gary you know what I love
about vaynermedia I'm like what and I
was pumped but it was actually a razz he
goes if I told you to get to the other
side of that wall you would 100% get
there the problem with Boehner sometimes
is you would and we were in a glass
office he's like you would run through
the glass and get cut to get there when
you could have just opened the door he
thought he was razzing me I was pumped I
was like cuz I got him back and it's fun
chess right I'm like brother the reason
you're paying me is cuz you usually pay
people who just sit in this room and
debate going to the door so I'm Pro
doing much more than I here I believe a
lot of my strategy comes from the ABCB
EF G testing that gave me the answer
more than than me thinking I can come up
with the answer however not having a
good strategy is always a vulnerability
too but it's a vulnerability of wasted
time that gives you context like this
investment earlier I've already won by
the bet this could go out of business
the learnings over next 36 months are
roi positive for the way I play so I
think you've got to know yourself
because other people are far I'm an
entrepreneur I'm not capable of sitting
down and doing type a work other
people's chemicals are type-a so for
them strategy might be the strength they
fear the doing because feedback and
negative feedback is scary the reason we
have so much unhappiness in this in the
Millennial demo is because the current
parents that raised them parents it the
most interesting dynamic I seen culture
right now is 48 to 70 year olds judging
millenials when they were the ones that
parented them they're the ones who
created eighth place trophies I didn't
grow up with eighth place trophies
they're the ones who decided that you
have to complement at scale even though
it's not true and thus your kids know
it's delusion and they become insecure
about everything because they don't know
which one's true or not so you have to
know yourself and I think you have to
lean into what comes natural whether
it's the gray or the black and white I
only am uncomfortable I'm only
comfortable in no and question marks
many need to do a ton of stuff before
they can make that jump if they try to
be like me they're gonna have anxiety in
the same way that I would have anxiety
to like put together a PDF no really
like if you asked me to make a deck
right now I would fold like a cheap
chair I'd be like do you rock you know
look over there and run away like you
know like I just can't I'm not capable
of doing it which is why I was such an
extremely poor student but luckily for
me at a very young age
I leaned into who I actually was and
went pot committed and it worked and I
want more of that for everybody in here
and you don't have to do it my way you
have to do it your way but and that's
why that's a very personal question but
those are the two ways but I believe I'm
a big fan of doing you
can't read about push-ups people love to
use strategy as a disguise for not
action léa léa léa full art needs to
meet you some from my perspective you
know looking at the history of how
sports in general has been has worked
and how its ingrained in education and
how it really starts in education yes
thinking about esports when it comes to
standing up some kind of structure just
like we've given to or you've given to
the rockers bringing that to k12 and
higher education what we don't you it
where that where that starts like it
starts earlier than the others so if you
rerolls yeah are playing versions of
esports right ii mm-hmm so if you were
to give structure to k-12 education and
higher education as far as by the way to
your point that will happen like how
many it clearly even the way you're
asking the question you know how many
scholarships are at the NCAA level what
do you think happens next the high
school you know what i mean that's
already happened the more insightful
thing you said is how it happens and who
gets who first and what i actually just
said my son goes to school for seven
minutes in his little drive with me
every day
and plays Madden mobile as a
seven-year-old in those seven minutes
really hard to practice your jump shot
on your seven-minute drive to school
Larry Bird and Magic Johnson both
famously woke up super early before
school to work on their game my son and
hundreds of millions of others will work
on their game in school in between
school getting the hall pass to go to
the bathroom to continue the game and
everything in between this is going to
be the sport one question I have had is
how are you going to deal with new
iterations of the game because I know
you know it's it's Modern Warfare this
year will it be modern warfare I don't
know because that's where the publisher
has disproportionate leverage
I think this sport is absolutely gonna
have a different dynamic where you make
a team based on the game and if the
publisher changes the game enough
in 24 months you might not have the
right talent to extract the upside so I
would argue this is actually one of the
things that excites me the most my
belief is that and not that I get to be
the GM or the coach but you know being
an ownership just having the DNA of
being most comfortable with changing
every day let alone every year like I
feel like that's exciting now if we went
back-to-back championships and then they
change it and we're still locked in in
contracts with the guys or gals that got
us there I may not be as pumped but I
come into eyes wide open I know that
that's the variable and and by the way
like all games evolve the NBA today I'm
a die-hard Knicks fan and the last time
they were good in the 90s the scores of
an NBA game were 86 to 79 now hardens
taking 90 shots a game so things evolve
anyway
this one may be a little bit more it's
not like the core rules you know my my
intuition is if but more likely when
this becomes legit that the publisher
will be thoughtful to not make it so
hardcore that teams get broke it you
know so I'm open for business I know
what we signed up for thank you
yep how are you sir good Jeff Tyler Jeff
so you grew up a Knicks fan I did you
watch basketball if the outside you keep
a fan of the Knicks free sports players
I mean they may play the game being a
fan maybe to learn more or to understand
the game better or they understand what
they're watching how does the outside
fan become a fan of eSports and will
sports betting find its way into eSports
number two yes Betty who finds its way
everywhere why don't you keep it Jeff
just in case there's a lot of jamming
here the 1982 NBA Finals were on tape
delay in America yep not live that's how
little interest cable right as you know
you know change so many things the
interest in different things everything
is based on the ability to consume it
right so when you think about the NFL
not being able to sell out Super Bowl 1
football itself not being a great sport
on radio versus what it was on
television all of this has ever been is
one big game of media consumption to
build awareness to build interest
the reason eSports is what I'm claiming
it is is predicated on the world where
actual consumption is and will continue
to grow in is native to eSports more
than its native to the other sports so
it again and this is what's so powerful
there are so many people that consume
eSports that are native to the
consumption platforms of twitch and
mixer and YouTube right you might not
get the 64 year old TV watcher because
occasionally something may show up on
ESPN or ABC but you completely own
everybody under the age of 25 it is
easier for 13-year old Charlie today in
school to consume eSports than the NHL
or the NBA the end I'll give you a great
comp
the reason boxing is no long you know
where I'm going is you're old enough to
live through the whole cycle and I am as
well thanks for but but and but i but i
but i throw myself in the same mix right
is and you had you know given probably
whatever our age gap is you have it you
had it even better than me I became a
boxing fan because I saw Michael Tyson
fights Michael Tyson fights on ABC wild
world sports and ESPN before he beat
Trevor Berbick to become the youngest
heavyweight champ cuz he was brutal and
wild and it was something cuz I could
see it he threw his insane popularity in
and for the youngsters in here you can't
imagine what Mike Tyson's popularity was
in 1987 like it was uncomfortable with
his with him and the heavyweight
division going where it went as you know
and money came in it all went
pay-per-view which meant guys and gals
like you and I couldn't watch it on
Saturday at morning no more ray beam
boom boom Mancini and Sugar Ray let the
real fights were on on Saturday morning
right that was awareness for free it
went pay
this was my point about major league
baseball baseball destroyed itself a
decade ago by creating BAM owning all
digital rights and not letting any of
the kids see anything if one of us put
up a video of Maur hitting a home run
here they took it down so that's why got
it because this has been written it's
funny I was an atrocious student but
there was one class
besides Jim that I got good grades and
it was history and and I never really
fully got it and only in the last two or
three years have I had an epiphany I'm
like huh I make so many of my business
decisions as an entrepreneur completely
predicated on history and and because
history will tell you the future this is
always if you look at it and this I've
done this so you'll appreciate this if
you look at horse-racing and boxing and
then football and basketball and
baseball this has been one big game of
what's available to be seen and what
fits the medium the best and eSports
fits the next medium the best yeah that
was super smart do you rock let's chop
that up let's get that on LinkedIn my
name is tyler authen actually from a
market research firm doing pretty good
we're working with communities that are
trying to build in-person venues so
they're kind of the early adopters of
maybe building facilities that are
dedicated for eSports yes it's not so
much a challenge it's just where things
are right now
you know viewership is off the charts
for eSports versus NFL it's it's more
people worldwide watch them that's right
that ratio though of people who've
attended an event you know is point zero
zero zero one percent of people who've
seen it online versus maybe 40 percent
of people who watch the NFL maybe a been
to a game that's probably high but it's
where it's absolutely the point you know
nature of both of the lineages the
histories and the technology stacks that
they were built on makes sense keep
going where do you see the opportunity
for live events and drawing audiences
that are 40 plus thousand high I think
it I think it's a foregone conclusion
and I'll tell you why when you look at
some of those it's nowhere at scale to
your point yet but if you look at some
of the indicators those
early things you know Madison Square
Gardens fastest sellout event right it's
there it's there and obviously one thing
that Americans do very poorly is look
outside of America South Korea can show
you this at scale so it just needs more
broad interest the education of the
parents is going to be enormous you know
like as we continue to see videos like
we just saw a lot of parents are gonna
realize if I want to connect with my
kids this I need to take them to this
instead of that concert or what my
favorite sport is that will happen and
the leagues themselves have to get their
act together like we haven't had
organized leagues we've had one-off
events we've had micro events but this
this again ufc's a great comp for this
it was very the way it was and then it
got consolidated proper media attention
proper story building a couple of
superstars and away you go the fact that
we have bugga and ninja already this
early on speaks to where all the pieces
are there so I just think this is just a
matter of time game I know you don't
make predictions but I'm if you had to
guess the timeline you know is there a
chance the rocker ever plays in US Bank
Stadium in 20 years here in 20 years
100% in five that's where it gets
challenging but all you need is what's
amazing about something that's already
happened is you just need one event
snapchat because we've all lived through
this in the last half decade snapchat
happened already
but it took DJ Khaled getting stuck in
the ocean on his jet ski to get
everybody to know snapchat happened this
league has happened already it might be
one clip of one interaction between
Minnesota and Chicago where the
intensity went and two of the players
got mad at each other and punched each
other in the face that hits the social
consciousness which then shows it and
that's where and that's why I don't know
I know it's done I know I'm invested
long I don't know the spa it was ashton
kutcher challenging CNN to get to a
million first that made everybody know
what Twitter was even though it already
happened Khalid unsnap I don't know
what's gonna happen for this league I
just know it's gonna happen
all of us here at some level no bug
winning three million dollars in one
tournament helped a lot of people that
didn't know no real quick because that
made AP national news something's gonna
happen
Michael strands gonna talk about it on
Good Morning America and then the
process will start that's America
thank you hey Tom Ferrara hey Tom
so my question is related to something
that you mentioned a little bit earlier
which is one of the roadblocks is media
dollars yes so we're seeing a lot of
participation in eSports you know up to
maybe even 80% is sponsorship and
partnership dollars I think that makes
sense for a lot of reasons it's it's
really close to what you would do with
like a traditional sports team deal
there's a lot of reasons why you'd want
access to this audience now but as soon
as that turns into and this is something
I face personally conversations with
media departments they tend to not be in
the know on this stuff and they want to
apply very traditional media metrics for
valuing that's how they're gonna buy or
promote correct content or exposure or
activations in the eSports space and
that's become a huge roadblock yes
what are your approaches or advice or
recommendations for trying to get worse
than 1,000 companies need to fire their
media agencies of record listen think
about what you're just saying you're a
hundred percent right and the reason
they do that is they make much more
money and buying traditional other
things or pro you know media agencies
love their black boxes of programmatic
because they're making tons of mark like
this is the business I'm actually in
full time it's a very easy answer it's
the same thing I have on social it's why
so many brands are declining a market
share the bested interest of the six
holding companies media departments and
their clients are completely in opposite
directions ninety percent of the media
spent in America is being spent through
a media agency that is a publicly traded
company that is trying to maximize its
own margin every 90 days how in the
world can that be a good service
provider so what's gonna happen one of
two things one we will continue to see
direct to consumer brands that don't
follow the same playbook continue to tap
into market share until the point of the
Kellogg's and the Unilever's and the
PepsiCo's gets so hurt that they'll
finally wake up and change their
positioning
on how they work with agency partners so
really it's a first mover advantage to
anyone who can find a way outside of
that traditional media model that's
right okay or you scare your current age
like what real life is you have enough
juice to go to your current agency stark
on media sure all those players and say
if you don't do this we will put up your
business for review because this is
strategically where I want to be because
I've never seen in the history of my
business life and I'm an entrepreneur
and around a bit and I've been I'm fast
so I've done a lot in 22 years I've
never seen the dynamic where the client
feels like the not client in the
relationship between brands and their
media agencies because of the contracts
that they signed that are being done at
the highest levels and and it's
destroying the Fortune 5000 brands
thank you yep hey Gary my name is max
Minsker I run the eSports team for the
Minnesota Timberwolves so my question
for you is based on kind of your
investment philosophy in terms of
eSports specifically so you've said that
eSports is it's kind of over already
right like it's happened and like if you
look at the viewership and the average
age of the audience and then some of
them even the metrics he was showing
regarding how to capture that audience
eSports obviously has a big market yes
and but for you when you're investing in
something like the rocker it's not like
a perfectly diversified ETF of an
eSports portfolio right it's a specific
investment in a specific property so
highly vulnerable exactly so my question
for you is how do you take that
knowledge of the industry and the macro
trends that are occurring and where the
audience is and translate that into like
a micro investment into one specific
property that might have more
vulnerability and then I think you don't
I think you need to amortize out your
bets right like to your point the
vulnerability of this investment which
was a hefty one for me is nobody wants
to play call of duty anymore
I don't know like there was Frogger was
awesome when I was a kid like meanwhile
basketball hasn't gone away on the flip
side we are now in the early stages of
games like Madden and 2k and others that
are like wow it's still here and it's
really here and Mario and Zelda and so
this is a this is a complete bet back to
the biggest point
you know cargo and the Wilfs like this
is a human thing for me as well that's
why I took both I actually publicly I'm
sure we can find video of it did not
want to invest in publishing IP team
sport like I just thought it was too
vulnerable to you know it's ultima
online was a precursor to all this like
I've watched I've been watching this was
a move for a lot of reason to me this is
a franchise that I feel hat first of all
this is a limited franchise this is a
global sport but first party shooter
Call of Duty is much more Americanized
than it is Asia the other things so
again very eyes wide open going into it
for me diversifying comes in a lot of
ways you know Vayner sports is very
focused from date the day AJ and I
started being sports which Iona's NFL
sports representation business we're up
thirty football players but from day one
eSports is the lead second sport we want
to get into when I started making this
deal I had to figure out like what which
side am I sitting on what can I do do I
have to rep people outside you know some
going through all that but that's huge -
look vaynermedia as a creative and media
agency is a thought leader in strategy
around this you know category so as you
can imagine me looking forward the way
I'm gonna hedge is I'm probably gonna
have an agency that's making 30 to 50
million in in consulting strategy and
creative output fee for helping brands
get into this space better I might bring
back ice hockey on Nintendo and be the
best player make 5 million a year
playing it I may invest in in whatever
emerges as the chuck-e-cheese or Buffalo
Wild Wings of this space like to me this
is how I do it if you look at all my
behavior it's why I built Manor
I built a communications Death Star
which gives me flexibility to go into
anything so ten years ago when I could
have raised a half a billion dollars on
the back of Facebook and Twitter and all
those great investments that I made that
put me on the map instead of going the
real easy route of high wealth creation
of raise a half a billion make ten
million a year to take meetings and have
20% of the upside of the bets off a
great track record I decided to build an
agency which is a grind super hard but I
knew I
building the comms stack to take
advantage of the diversification of
macro the-- so does that affect how you
think about the revenue of this property
on a year-to-year basis because you can
diversify yeah I don't think about the
revenue of this business
on a yearly basis at all just make
payroll don't go out of business that
when you bet long and in perpetuity we
live through a time now where everyone's
building businesses to sell them
I only build businesses to die with them
when you do that all you have to do is
just stay alive when you're betting on
what you know is right good Andrey bort
naav with up city younger hi Gary
nice to meet you too first time thank
you quick question first I've seen you
seeing you a consume your content
understand kind of maybe this is maybe
more of a macro question but in terms of
marketing strategy and consumer
attention yes what would be the
difference or is there a difference
between eSports and traditional sports
on what platforms do you think eSports
would dominate Thanks no question hold
on to the mic just in case so there's a
lot of differences first of all I
believe that eSports even with the macro
League deals or title deals or team
deals is grossly underpriced in
comparison to the price you pay in
traditional sports because there are
amateur asset and what they want in
return for step and repeats and patches
and integrations is so much more
expensive even though these numbers are
not small anymore because the audience
is there but still paying for an NHL
integration and you're trying to reach
fifteen to thirty year old males you're
gonna get ripped off in the NHL in
comparison to eSports just on the sheer
attention as far as platforms to your
point and this was to the gentleman
behind you that I'm looking at this
sports ability to be 100 percent native
to twitch and YouTube and Instagram and
thinks that nature is a huge advantage I
mean when you look I mean the NHL
watched baseball do the wrong thing was
losing relevance and then
the deal with BAM I mean there's not a
person you know we're in Minnesota and I
think the majority this room would
struggle to name ten hardcore all-stars
outside of wild players like it's it's
it's a mistake anyway nonetheless I
think that um I think that look at the
NBA the NBA takes far more of a
superstar build brand we know more six
men on NBA teams than we know all-stars
in the NHL and Major League Baseball so
I think that one I think it's
underpriced I think if you you call
rocker and you call the wild and you try
and your focus is a certain demo now if
your focus is $200,000 income fifty to
275 male middle America then all of a
sudden I want to talk hockey so it
depends on your strategy but the reality
is some things are just grossly
underpriced and I think for the next
half decade there'll be a lot of
arbitrage opportunities for association
with what happens in this sector whether
in this league the platform's the
individual humans you know I talked to
Ty I talked to ninja and his first deals
he gets paid a lot more now than he did
then you were stealing ninjas equity in
those first 25 deals then he got William
Morris then he became ninja the way we
know him and all of a sudden what used
to be able to get for free product or
$10,000 becomes $250,000 for five
minutes the game thanks yep
hey what's up Kerry thanks man my name
is Josh Josh three questions real quick
first is what happens when you own the
Jets and your now friend amis with the
Wilf family what does that look like I'm
going to try to beat their faces it much
like the Wilf screwup insane
over-the-top giant fans and I'm sure
when they face the Giants they're not
rooting for the Giants yeah I hope not I
hope not doubt it
second question who's the most
interesting person you've ever met
that's interesting I would say the most
interesting meeting I ever had was with
Mark Zuckerberg when I spoke to Facebook
when they had 200 employees I didn't
know him obviously Facebook was starting
to roll I spoke to the company I didn't
know he's in there he was way in the
back he came down he asked me I had a
flight right after the talk and he goes
how long are you in Palo Alto and I was
smart enough to be like oh I'm leaving
tomorrow and he's like you won't have
dinner I said yes and I'll never forget
this obviously Facebook was already huge
even though they were a small amount of
employees we had dinner and I remember
thinking I believe that I am a
one-dimensional player I believe that I
understand human being so well that
every other aspect of what I do I'm a
verage at but I'm so remarkable at
consumer behavior and being and when I
said by the way when I deliver something
like I'm so remarkable complete luck of
the draw of mom and dad having sex at
the right moment complete natural luck
of Deanne complete I take no pride and I
love giving the daps to my parents I
love giving the DAPs to my circumstance
but and and I've never met somebody in
my life up until that point that I
thought was deeply and utterly consumer
blindly human-centric I am an extrovert
and an outward personality so one could
kind of make an assumption to that he is
a technologist and introverted and and
even I'm sure when you've seen him on
Capitol Hill or other places that would
stun you that that is his great suit to
this day not President Barack Obama not
Bill Clinton not many other people that
you know I've never sat across from
somebody that I felt Jedi like oh wait a
minute you know to and makes sense
that's why I built Facebook
that's awesome and a perfect segue to
this last question what's the most
badass Jedi book you've ever read read
read so I've read like four books in my
life and I would have to say the the
biography of Barbara Walters I actually
believe that Barbara Walters may be one
of the most underrated contemporary
personalities of the last 50 years I
know you didn't see that one coming
hey URI are you glad good to see you
again
very excited have you on copy closes
next year yeah so here's my question you
know you were talking about being ahead
of the curve and where this is headed I
think we've all been convinced this is a
very exciting time to see where this
goes are there any for the average
investor are there any products or
companies right now that you could list
off that we should be paying attention
to or investing in now the answer is I'm
sure I haven't done the homework so the
answer is I don't know but I do think
this is a I will give you an answer that
maybe helps you bring some answers some
insight that might help you always look
at the picks and the shovels I'm very
vulnerable with this hefty seven-figure
investment because if this title is in
contemporary in 15 years I'm vulnerable
picks and shovels got it so whether it's
private public market or something else
pay attention to people that are
building infrastructure around this
movement evergreen not at the mercy of
twitch or you like that thank you thank
you and I appreciate that and it's a
really important insight you know a lot
of us will gamble or I don't feel this
is a gamble what I'm gonna learn over
the next three years is gonna do more
for me than the investment whether this
exists or not
the people that I'm gonna be associated
with the learnings practicing to be an
owner you know that stuff but for you
know I it was only five minutes ago that
a $25,000 check was very scary for me to
bet and with what and what I tried to do
was bet on what I knew or what had
already happened or picks and shovels
right look at search engines and
browsers in
a structure right so what's the
infrastructure what what doesn't rely on
it being fortnight or Call of Duty or
Activision as a business that can just
flow if in four years it is frogger or
there's two girls in Nashville right now
inventing an IP that becomes the game
for 10 years how does that company take
advantage of that versus get hurt by it
in perpetuity evergreen picks and
shovels I have a question for you please
so Joe McIntosh and first of all
Nintendo ice hockey three fat guys one
skinny I don't thank God touch me that's
good don't think you get to throw if you
find yourself in New York no kidding
it's Gary vaynermedia let's go the other
question I have is the other question I
had is by the way to give him gaps the
three fat one skinny is my lineup too
I told you I told you if I didn't say
this guy knows a little something by the
way for anybody doesn't know we're
talking about the way the game starts is
you get to like pick your team you pick
your team it's Olympic style
I'm always Russia because I was born in
the Soviet Union and and then you get a
skinny a fat or a medium guy in there
for spots and you kind of put it
together the hack is three fat guys and
a skinny so I'm a little bit worried
about Joe makes sense Minnesota hockey
culture all right brother I see you so
so my question is you know I'm sitting
here listen to you talk and I feel like
man anything this guy touches seems like
it would turn to gold right it's just
like you have this energy you have this
passion and I'm thinking about you know
myself and my world you know how can I
bring that same energy same passion
you'll see I sold widgets right and I
saw widgets to 65 year-old men yeah
right it's like they're clueless about
you know the to what's going on in
reality it you know the twenty
six-year-old and below I'm just like you
know coach that well couple things to
talk about with this one they may not
have to worry about it right so for
example you've heard me mention
tick-tock a couple times that the other
platform in the world of marketing today
that I'm obsessed with is LinkedIn
LinkedIn's organic Reach is so
uncomfortably high it's Facebook 2012
and as you can imagine
and I see the body language here you're
clearly gonna reach different people on
LinkedIn than you are on tik-tok and
that 65 year old male decision-maker I
don't know when he or she is buying that
widget are they actually targeting 15 to
35 right so to me it's funny it's like
so I'm very fortunate in the fact that
my passion is agnostic all I do is day
trade attention and behavior and it's a
very important sentence it's day trading
so I'm not paka guys my I how many
people here follow me pretty closely on
social just for context so thank you so
you noticed over the last year have done
a lot of recall videos on Instagram
where I show you me saying something in
2008 and showing it again
like that's back to not guessing like
you get the equity of reputation I'm not
just jumping on now I was right but it
wasn't predicting it was because those
things had already happened the thing
I'm most waiting for is 15 years from
now when I'm completely [ __ ] on
social media the way I would talk about
print and direct mail right because I'm
not committed to anything I'm just pop
committed to the ability to daily daily
I wrote my last book which is how to win
on social content distribute right now
it's only 18 months old not a mention of
LinkedIn or tik-tok having that you know
so you know free couple things one are
you it has to start with the truth are
you actually passionate of selling
widgets in a b2b environment to bring
like I failed all my classes if you told
me right now to hang a picture on the
wall I would like jump out the window no
passion don't want to do that stuff take
out the trash no read no write back to
the book it starts with self-awareness
the greatest gift I was given was
conviction and self-awareness I know
what I'm good at I know when I'm bad at
my parents built cell my mom built
self-esteem so I was able to deal with
judgment I was a terrible student during
the greatest era of it needing to be
good at school to be successful I was
making six thousand dollars a weekend
as a 14-year old and told everyday by my
friends parents and my teachers that I
was a loser if I was making six thousand
dollars a weekend today selling sports
cards I'd be on like cover of magazines
like like now we Herald fourteen year
olds making money that's the culture now
entrepreneurship got cool again you know
so to answer question many things one do
they even need to care about these
things cuz there's no reason you know if
you're an executive or you're wrapping
up your career or whatever you it has to
be practical I'm practical number two
you have to look within yourself how old
are you 43 so for me you and I are part
of a really interesting generation
because we're I just turned 44 now I
know the skinny and fast I get it you
look younger you look good bro
the-the-the the biggest one of the
biggest things I'm hoping that I can
communicate to the world through this
newfound attention is our unbelievable
ability inability excuse me to have a
good relationship with time every twenty
two-year-old wants it to happen tomorrow
and every forty three-year-old
doesn't think that they can take a hard
left and completely start over because
they don't realize they're gonna live
for another fifty-two years our complete
and utter atrocious relationship with
time is leading to an enormous amount of
unhappiness and so like I see you and
even just like the energy and how you
ask the question like I was compelled
I'm like bro you might just need to
really look at yourself in the mirror
tonight and say one step backwards three
steps forward happiness has to be the
ROI you know and I think if you really
if you could feel in your bones another
29 years of a professional career all of
a sudden when you look at it that way
versus I'm 43 and look at all these kids
doing it at 19 if you look at it as 29
more years before I even debate slowing
down then all of a sudden sounds
practical to maybe say I don't wanna
[ __ ] sell widgets anymore so that's
the stuff that goes through my mind
thank you yep
you can imagine you wonder to
thirty-year-olds and here what I think
for you like so much time so much time
Garrett Sam Schwartz from Duke Canon and
hasten so good to see you um I got a 101
whack
oh yeah I hope you like it if you don't
don't tweet about it I will on 101
question I'm gonna ask of baseball
history which I hope you appreciate so
as you know in the early days of
baseball
there wasn't an MLB a bunch of
independence right so I wonder about is
there a parallel here whereby yes is
will there be a bunch of Li yes
competing for players and resources
baseball hockey football of course
history yes will there be other well a
well-heeled investor come in and start
their own call of duty and EGH okay so
how do we met how do we place the right
bet then be consumer-centric the USFL
would still be operating if they stayed
in the spring
that's what's great about the game it's
just merit wine.com raised 240 million
dollars when I launched Wine Library
comm with $30,000 in marketing I won
money is not scary being delusional is
you like that one it's good one what's a
little gangster I like that clip that
d-roc it's true though
like how many examples do you want of
something super well-funded not
defeating the thing that was
consumer-centric
like I said I'm not a genius there's
47,000 examples google it it happens
every day of the week because a lot of
times you know I think I've been the
worst points of my career is when I've
had money in the pocket I'm at my best
when I don't have it
thank you so much for your time
[Applause]